Every so often some big idea happens, but it might be one person.
Ideas in what, in the space of engineering or is it in a space?
So one of the limits of computer performance is branch predictions. So,
and there's a,
there's a whole bunch of ideas about how good you could predict a branch.
And people said there was a limit to it to not spin Tata curve.
And somebody came up with a better way to do branch prediction.
It was a lot better and he published a paper on it and every computer in the
world now uses it. And it was one idea. So the,
the engineers who build branch picks and hardware,
we're happy to drop the one kind of training array and put it in another one.
So it was, it was a real idea.
And branch,
as one of the key problems underlying all of,
sort of the lowest low software, it boils down to branch. The prediction.
Boils down, the uncertainty,
computers are limited by single-threaded computers limited by two things, the,
the predictability of the path of the branches and the predictability of the
locality of data.
So we have predictors that now predict both of those pretty well. Yeah.
So memory is, you know, a couple hundred cycles away.
The local cash has a couple cycles away when you're executing fast,
virtually all the data has to be in the local cache. So a simple program says,
you know, add one to every element and array.
It's really easy to see what the stream of data will be,
but you might have a more complicated program that's, you know,
so was good to get an element of this Ray,
look at something and make a decision and go get another element it's kind of
random. And you can think that's really unpredictable.
And then you make this big predictor that looks at this kind of pattern and you
realize, well, if you get this data and this data,
then you probably want that one.
And if you get this one and this one and this one, you probably want that one.
And is that theory or is that engineering like the paper that was written?
Was it a symbiotic kind of kind of discussion or is it more like here's a hack
that works well?
Um, it's a little bit of both like there's information theory in it,
I think somewhere. Okay. There's actually trying to prove, but once, once,
you know, the method implementing it is an engineering problem.